800 years ago someone little more than a
fable a folk hero a myth foretold of his
own return at the dawn of a new era
few stories are known of this
character's Renown but all who do know
his name fervently await his return
the one known as The Warrior of
liberation
the one known
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
I'm not here to tell you everything that
we know about Joy boy which isn't a lot
I couldn't stretch that into a full
eight minute video nor am I just gonna
break down this episode it's silly it's
fun there's not much more to do than
just enjoy and bask in the moment that
we're witnessing and that is what I'm
actually going to talk about this moment
because the way that year fifth has
taken over the internet and the world in
the past few weeks past months is
honestly unheard of with an anime in a
long time epic dramatic transformations
in anime are for the most part a thing
of the past now no no that that doesn't
mean they don't exist anymore it's a
forgotten Trend anything like that don't
get me wrong but the importance that
shows put on these moments nowadays
compared to how it used to be is
drastically different
the current slate of anime mostly builds
type of let's say almost comparable
Heights to gear fifth almost by just
progressing getting to the end of course
that's huge we've seen this with Attack
on Titan crashing Crunchyroll frequently
when new episodes dropped or the show
will do an insane fight look at the end
of Demon Slayer season 2.
look at the Epic return of bleach after
a decade of no talks of finishing the
anime there's a lot of reasons that
shows build hype but look at how anime
used to be long-running shows where you
could make a top 50 list of every
transformation and why they're better
than the last
when one piece came out this was the
style of Shonen Jump Naruto had a new
Jutsu new sharinganu upgrade of the
nine-tailed fox coming out every two
years Ichigo got bangkai in a three-day
training Arc and then 300 episodes later
was able to fight Eisen one of anime's
most overpowered characters by far by
training for a little less than three
months in the dongai we love these
moments they're epic they showcase that
our characters have no limits we're
utterly and completely shocked by the
epicness of a new transformation
the anime scene has gone through a huge
shift away from that being the show's
Central moments making it all the more
impressive that there is no one who in
the past year has come even remotely
close to one piece in terms of building
and delivering on hype and yes as we
know it's for a power up
and don't contest me on whether or not
this is the most hype moment of the year
two years whatever even as a
non-one-piece fan you cannot deny the
waves that one piece has sent through
the world recently and I can attribute
this hype to a list that I call gear
fits recipe for success
[Music]
first animation
if you don't know or really just can't
tell one piece has undergone a huge
overhaul in its animation level over the
past Arc in wano I've been watching one
piece and reading it ever since 2017.
I've made multiple videos over my time
as a YouTuber on it I've been there
through a lot of the worst and best of
the show and to witness the amount of
effort that toei is now putting into a
weekly anime a show that never stops is
absolutely incredible almost every show
out there now is broken up into cores
with long breaks between them you spend
a year waiting for season two to come
out or in the case of Attack on Titan
you wait a year for a single episode I'm
joking I like Attack on Titan 2 Guys
but one piece comes out every week and
it has animation on this level
that alone is unheard of fight after
fight where different lead animators
come together to make it better and
better every week and that has also
culminated in this episode where not
even joking an Avengers level team of
animators have come together and worked
for eight months on this episode while
the show was airing the whole time
no one piece doesn't have the best
animation no historically it hasn't had
that but right now it's consistency and
emphasis on really good animation for
the most important episodes in a series
that constantly goes every single week
is nothing short of impressive after
witnessing sanji's fight and Zorro's
fight I don't think there's a single
Anime Watcher who isn't insanely excited
to see exactly what they do with Luffy's
that has built a huge amount of hype
but also so has number two the impact of
joyboy
a lot of non-one-piece Watchers will
drag gear fifth for being another lame
power-up it's funny how a decade or two
earlier it would be indisputably epic
for everyone to witness another power up
from the world's biggest anime but now
it gets dragged by non-fans for being
random cheesy out of nowhere
but that's because they don't know just
how important this power-up is to the
show to the story and the foreshadowing
that has been built up to this moment
joyboy is a mysterious figure from the
void Century who has had a number of
parallels to Luffy now whose return has
been hinted at starting at Fishman
Island hundreds and hundreds of episodes
ago years ago the importance of Luffy's
devil fruit which was taken and held by
Shanks an emperor of the sea and former
crewmate of the pirate king himself this
isn't just some random fruit this isn't
some random power-up
painting Luffy as the warrior of
Liberation as a character who will free
others and fight with a smile on his
face is exactly what we've always known
him for
with the exception of whole cake Island
every single one of the post-time skip
arcs the straw hats have been liberators
Fishman Island freeing them from hodi's
oppression Punk Hazard freeing the
countless kids from Caesar's experiments
dress Rosa the people freed from
doflamingo so the people freed from
Jack's constant torture carried out in
order to find rhizo and wano of course
freeing the country from kaido and
arochi's reign
not an art goes by where Luffy doesn't
win over the people not by his strength
only but by his smile and infectious joy
for the pursuit of one piece for his
pure heart that they know would always
save them if they needed it
gear fifth is a moment that one piece
fans have both knowingly and unknowingly
been waiting for
and for it to occur at the culmination
of Luffy vs kaido
450 plus episodes of build up gear 4th
bounce man snakeman future sight
observational hockey these all now pale
in comparison to what is happening at
this moment because it is the return of
Joy boy
this isn't just a power up it's an
important story moment and something
that will change one piece forever
that is exactly why this isn't just a
lame power-up
and you might be wondering just what is
the last reason that I think this moment
is so so important to the world right
now and that I think
is manga readers
how often is it that you see manga
readers actually being praised for their
help in the anime version it's not often
but I must give credit where it's due
because everyone knows that gear fifth
is coming even toy released a trailer
weeks in advance Anime Expo made a huge
blow up balloon in his new form a month
before it happened statues are already
being made anime onlys know that Gear
Fit is here
but no one is mad
no one is pissed about spoilers or
wanting to wait for the anime somehow
everyone is coming together to celebrate
this moment even if you've already read
it or if you have no idea what's to come
it doesn't matter
manga readers have now had a good amount
of time to sit on this transformation
and let it marinate and the beauty of it
and our appreciation of it has only
increased with time
depreciation for joyboy's reveal how the
cartoonish nature and fun of the moment
perfectly leans into Luffy's character
growth and personality that we've
witnessed over 1 000 plus episodes
manga fans have slowly and safely been
hyping up this moment to animate on
these and I think that's really
beautiful to see I think it speaks to
how amazing this moment in time is not
just as a one-piece moment but a space
and time that won't be forgotten across
all of anime and manga a moment when
anime fans and manga fans come together
and truly just appreciate a moment for
what it is
and look I I know I didn't give a
breakdown and Analysis any of that but
that's because I think that this moment
in the world is far more important to
highlight than any specific aspect of
the episode
One Piece episode 1071 won't be
forgotten by any of us the tick tocks
the tweets everything has been building
up to this day one piece fans
the show's not even done but
I think we already won
[Music]
as always this has been the anime
culture corner I hope you enjoyed the
video don't forget to like And subscribe
for future in-depth show manga and
character analyzes